[Musique]
les deux politiques bonsoir et bienvenue
dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez vous
du dimanche soir ce radio sensations en
association avec tv sont 18 épisodes 216
mon invité ce soir et la vice présidente
du conseil départemental des yvelines
pauline vino cours le fèvre
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique
pauline vinocur lefebvre bonsoir ça vous
êtes vice présidente du conseil
départemental des yvelines en charge de
l'agriculture de la ruralité de
l'alimentation et des circuits courts ce
week-end s'est ouvert porte de
versailles le traditionnel salon de
l'agriculture dans les yvelines les
terres agricoles
représentent 39 % du territoire ce n'est
donc pas rien le salon de l'agriculture
c'est l'occasion de mettre en avant ces
secteurs de le faire connaître davantage
oui on va le faire connaître davantage
non il est bien connu des ventes est de
42 % des terres agricoles moi je lis me
semble et il est bien connu c'est
surtout l'occasion
réaffirmer s'il en était besoin que les
yvelines soit un territoire
majoritairement mal d'un point du rural
et agricole louis d'un point de vue
géographique
que c'est une activité économique
extrêmement importante pour le
département des yvelines est de
réaffirmer tout notre soutien aux
agriculteurs et à leurs activités le
département sera présent au salon de la
biture il y aura il y aura un stand
yvelines hauts-de-seine les deux
départements sont très complémentaires
dans le domaine agricole pourquoi un
stand commun au salon de l'agriculture
alors
dans un premier temps les yvelines ont
démarré seul et puis il ya eu ce projet
de rapprochement yvelines hauts de seine
avec
une mutualisation d'un certain nombre de
nos politiques et à partir de ce moment
là la décision a été prise d'avoir un
stand commun au salon de l'agriculture
il ya une forme de alors complémentarité
je sais pas parce que les hauts-de-seine
ne sont pas un département agricole en
revanche il ya des synergies à mettre en
oeuvre c'est à dire que nous nous avons
le foncier nous avons les agriculteurs
et les productions et les hauts-de-seine
ont un bassin de consommateurs
importants et je pense notamment à ce
que met en oeuvre le département en
matière de circuits courts dans les
cantines de nos collèges on souhaite que
nos collégiens c'est dans le cahier des
charges que nous avons signé avec la
société qui exploite les cantines de nos
collèges nous souhaitons dans les
assiettes des collégiens il y ait des
produits vinoy c'est quelque chose qu'on
est en train de déployer dans le
département des yvelines et le
département des hauts-de-seine à des
collèges des collégiens à nourrir et la
même demande alors ce sera pas ça pourra
pas être des produits alto séquanais
puisqu'il ya pas de production ou à la
marge des productions maraîchères dans
les hauts-de-seine en revanche il y à il
ya des vrais
des vrais partenariats à construire vous
avez parlé de 2006 alisation des
politiques des deux départements où ça
on est aujourd'hui ça continue d'avancer
nos services notre direction des
mobilités et communes par exemple pour
ce qui est là la gestion de nos routes
départementales
il y à un établissement d'accueil
d'adultes handicapés qui a vu le jour
aux mureaux et qui est porté par nos
deux départements voilà un certain
nombre de choses se mettent en oeuvre
progressivement à chaque fois que c'est
que c'est opportun que c'est plus
efficace parce que vous avez un souvenir
particulier de votre enfance adolescence
au salon de l'agriculture
de mon enfance adolescence non mais deux
des récentes visites que j'ai pu le
faire depuis j'ai chez les élus oui
c'est un
je suis toujours très frappé par
l'utilisation qu'on peut faire des
nouvelles technologies en agriculture je
crois que c'est absolument fascinant et
donc pour vous donner un exemple
canton il ya une technique de
de traitement pour les maïs pour
détruire la pyrale du maïs sans utiliser
de produits phytos est toujours un peu
de technique on utilise des larves de
trichogrammes qui vont pondre dans la
larve de la pyrale donc les agricultures
qui font ça les agriculteurs qui font ça
c'est dans des procès sont déjà
arraisonné ou de lutte biologique les
agriculteurs qui font ça en des petites
plaquettes avec les larves à différents
stades de maturité qui vont déposer dans
les maïs vous voyez la taille d'un champ
de maïs il faut tous les x m avait
déposé sa petite tablette lala clip et
sur la plante et c'est tout à fait
biodégradables et au salon de
l'agriculture la dernière fois que j'y
suis allé il y avait un drone qui sait
ce boulot là à la place de l'agriculteur
et qui lâchait dans les parcelles des
petites boules biodégradables qui
contenait la larve de de cet insecte qui
étaient lâchés dans l'est dans les
champs est alors le gros avantage c'est
que ça peut avec la technique du drone
on peut aussi travailler avec les
cartographies des parcelles qu'on a et à
les lâcher alors que ce soit des larves
ou que ce soit des produits phyto
d'ailleurs allez lâchez les traitements
là où c'est nécessaire avec des dosages
extrêmement précis nécessaire et tout ça
concourt à une agriculture
plus respectueuse de l'environnement
plus dynamique et plus performante et je
suis toujours très fasciné par ces
petits drones alors qu'on nous montre au
salon de l'agriculture et qui ont
vocation à
survoler les champs je trouve ça très
intéressant
la recherche continue la grève sur ce ne
cesse de se réinventer pourquoi est ce
que vous aviez vous avez déjà très
particulier pour pour ce domaine
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez été choisi
pour prendre la vice-présidence au
département alors j'ai été élu sur un
canton très majoritairement rural le
canton d'aubergenville
mais c'est un canton nord sud au coeur
des yvelines est majoritairement dans sa
partie rurale et donc agricole et
après pourquoi j'ai été choisi alors
faudrait demander à pierre bédier
pourquoi il m'a choisi toujours est il
que que j'ai grandi dedans puisque je
suis fille petite fille arrière petite
fille d'agriculteur et et que c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours intéressé
même si je suis pas agricultrice moi
même mais vous avez en tout cas la
légitimité familial le département des
yvelines est le deuxième département
agricole ile de france derrière la seine
et marne alors que produit ton dans les
yvelines comme comme produits ont
produit beaucoup de choses à une très
très grande diversité mais on est
majoritairement un
département qui produit de grandes
cultures donc céréales et
oléoprotéagineux en majorité on voit
d'ailleurs quand on se promène sur nos
comptes qu'elle soit départementales ou
pas d'ailleurs on voit bien la
prédominance des grandes cultures
comment est-ce que donc quel bilan
faites vous du quinquennat maquereau en
matière d'agriculture la loi votée la
loi et galim de encadre les échanges
entre les agriculteurs les
transformateurs et les distributeurs
pour mieux protéger les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui sur le terrain à quel retour
est ce que vous avez de cette loi qui
devrait rentrer en vigueur en 2023
alors
on a le
cette idée de protéger
l'agriculteur
elle aura duré pendant tout le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron c'est une
bonne chose a une fin il fallait le
prendre en compte il ya une première loi
et galim qui est visiblement
insuffisantes on en fait une deuxième
reste à savoir si elle sera elle aussi
suffisante pour l'instant moi ce que
j'ai entendu c'est qu'ils manquaient des
décrets d'application qui avait un
certain nombre de questions en suspens
et est toujours une inquiétude et des
producteurs pour savoir si ce sera
suffisamment protecteur pour eux ou pas
l'idée si j'ai bien compris c'est
c'est de dire et puis ça semble
tellement logique c'est de dire qu'il
faut que celui qui produit soit rémunéré
à la juste valeur de ce qu'il a produit
et que ça couvre pas seulement ses frais
de production mais que ça lui permette
aussi de dégager des marges qui lui
permettent ensuite de vivre correctement
et de réinvestir pour son exploitation
ça semble extrêmement logique en fait ce
genre de préoccupations
marche pour tout toutes sortes
d'entreprises aucun entrepreneur
acceptent de travailler à perte ou
ou de rentrer juste à peine dans ses
frais c'est pas c'est pas acceptable
donc ça protège sa vocation à protéger
les agriculteurs et a fixé le prix
agricoles à le négocier et à ce qu'une
fois négocier ils soient fixées dans des
qui ne bougent plus et que ce soit
satisfaisant maintenant comment vont se
passer les négociations comment vont
être négocier les prix voilà il ya
encore beaucoup d'interrogations d'après
ce que j'ai pu voir et comprendre des
producteurs de manifester le 11 février
dernier devant le siège de carrefour
dénonçant la non application encore de
la loi galim 2 les problèmes ne seront
pas encore totalement résolue
on a souvent cette image de
l'agriculteur qui fait grève qui
manifestent ce qui énervait ce que c'est
de l'image aussi que vous avez vous non
alors faire grève non il fait pas grève
il peut pas faire grève l'agriculteur
le bourg la loi et galim vous l'avez dit
c'est 2023 et galim 2 donc elle elle
fonctionne il ya encore des choses à
mettre en oeuvre rien n'est complètement
figé encore
ce que j'ai entendu c'est qu'ils
manifestaient parce qu'enfin il ya une
inquiétude il ya une hausse du coût des
matières premières et donc des coûts de
production et est une une incertitude
quant à la prise en compte de cette
hausse
dans les prix de vente de leur produits
après donc non je pense qu'ils ont
raison de se faire entendre après je ne
suis pas là pour juger de leurs méthodes
et de la façon dont ils le font mais
quand ils se font entendre
c'est qu'il ya vraiment un problème vous
le demandiez tout à l'heure quelles
qu'aient les événements ou quels
éléments avaient pu marquer au salon
d'agriculture moi il ya quelque chose
qui m'avait beaucoup marqué il ya
quelques années c'était pas au salon de
l'agriculture
mais c'était une grosse manif de
d'agriculteurs qui allaient à paris
montrer leur mécontentement et je trouve
que je les avais croisé dans l'autre
sens sur la route et c'était des
centaines et des centaines de tracteurs
qui allaient à paris et c'était
extrêmement poignant parce que c'était
le on sentait qu'ils n'en pouvaient plus
quoi c'était il exprimait vraiment un
ras-le-bol c'est une profession faut pas
oublier ce qu'elle fait cette profession
c'est quand même une les agriculteurs
qui nous nourrissent il en va de notre
autonomie alimentaire c'est quand même
pas rien on a tendance à l'oublier parce
qu'on n'est grâce au ciel des
générations qui n'avons jamais connu la
guerre dans les années 50 quand on leur
a demandé de produire et s'ils
produisent comme ils le font aujourd'hui
c'est parce que l'enjeu était de nourrir
les petits français
il est grand mais de nourrir la france
et l'europe aujourd'hui on a un peu
tendance à l'oublier et
et avoir des réactions de personnes tout
à fait privilégié qui n'ont jamais
souffert de la faim qui ont plutôt vu l
inverse d des excès
alimentaires c'était pas le cas
autrefois et il ya toujours le risque
qu'un jour ça ne soit plus le cas donc
il faut bien avoir en tête et toutes ces
négociations sur notre agriculture c'est
c'est notre autonomie alimentaire qui
est qui est au bout du chemin en fait on
entend souvent dire que l'agriculture
est un tournant de son histoire
notamment
pour prendre en compte les enjeux
environnementaux
vous est ce que c'est votre vision aussi
que l'agriculture change actuellement et
entendra est en train de
se modifier de d'évoluer pour pour aller
vers plus de biopuces de plus de
deux verres voilà un tournant alors je
sais pas si c'est un tournant
elle évolue je vous parlais des petites
techniques de drones tout à l'heure elle
peut s'appuyer sur la science sur les
nouvelles technologies sur la recherche
c'est extrêmement important
c'est on a on a toujours l'impression
que la grande à une vision de
l'agriculteur qui est le paysan avec sa
fourche c'est plus du tout ça
l'agriculture c'est extrêmement
technique
extrêmement à la pointe
oui elle doit prendre en compte ces
évolutions sociétales et cette nécessité
de préserver notre environnement de
c'est quand même un gros sujet si ce
n'est le sujet
d'aujourd'hui
est la plus je sais pas si c'est ce que
j'aime pas dans le mot tournant c'est
que ça sous-entend qu'on va
arrières tout où on comprend
complètement une autre direction non
l'enjeu reste le même l'enjeu ça reste
de nous nourrir de nourrir correctement
avec des produits de qualité et
des produits dont on connaît l'origine
quand on sait comment ils sont fabriqués
et c'est
donc je pense que plus qu'un tournant
elle est face à un champ de possibilités
pour rester dans la métaphore rural avec
le champ un champ de possibilités
infinies grâce à tout ce que les
nouvelles techniques peuvent peuvent
nous apporter parce que quand bien même
on continue à utiliser des phyto dans
les champs on le fait différemment on le
fait de façon plus ciblée de façon plus
légère on n'est pas dans l'épandage
massif
comme peut-être ça a été le cas
autrefois je suis encore une fois pardon
pour répondre à une demande bien
particulière faut pas oublier d'où on
vient dans les années 50 et ce en quoi
est ce à quoi entend aujourd'hui chaque
année le département des yvelines aide
les agriculteurs à hauteur de 800 mille
euros alors comment est ce que vous
utilisez cet argent et
qui est-ce qui est ce que vous aider
justement est ce qu'il ya des critères
de sélection pour avoir ces aides à
temps la vision de la politique des
événements en la matière qui on est
passé à vous l'avez dit les agriculteurs
je dirais qu'il ya deux volets
principaux dans notre politique
départementale on a deux outils
maison si j'ose dire des outils
départementaux un plan d' aides à
l'investissement sur un certain nombre
d'investissements qui ne peuvent pas
être accompagné par d'autres d'autres
cèdent sur lesquelles je reviendrai
après on est partenaire de la région
notamment et un programme départemental
des deux projets d'intérêt local qui l'a
sont moins tourner vers des agriculteurs
que vers des projets des porteurs de
projets qui peuvent être associatif mais
avec une langue en lien avec
l'agriculture absolument
se
et le deuxième volet de nos z c'est ans
participent au programme de
développement rural
puis alimenté par des fonds européens et
qui est géré par la région et au
programme leader au territoire leader il
y en a deux dans les yvelines on a un
leader sur le plateau de saclay est un
leader en seine aval donc là le
département est partenaire sur un
certain nombre de projets des qs donc ça
ce sont les deux volets principaux on a
aussi un fonds de soutien aux calamités
naturelles une aide à la protection
intégrée du blé mais les deux volets
principaux ce sont ces deux là après ça
reste des aides à l'investissement donc
à l'achat de matériel à la construction
de bâtiments
c'est assez divers nous ce qu'on a mis
en place au niveau départemental
on voulait que ce soit très souple que
ça réponde rapidement aux besoins des
agriculteurs et c'est quelque chose dont
on reparle régulièrement avec les
services du département et qu'on
retravaille régulièrement quand on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un volet qui est pas
suffisamment mobilisé on essaye de
savoir si c'est parce qu'il n'est pas
connu par nos exploitants ou six parce
que
il n'est pas attractif auquel cas on
essaie de réajuster le but c'est
vraiment de répondre à des besoins et
une demande et on accompagne tous types
de projets alors bien volé pour les
projets diversification agricole donc ça
peut être la construction d'un hangar de
stockage l'acquisition de matériel
frigorifique pour du maraîchage par
exemple tout ce qui est transformation
également quand des agriculteurs se
lance dans la transformation
récemment par exemple on a accompagné un
exploitant qui veut transformer du soja
en tofu on l'a aidé à
acquérir du matériel pour pour cette
transformation
tout ce qui concourt également à
utiliser moins de produits moins de
produits phyto à retenir l'eau à éviter
l'érosion des sols après je vous passe
les outils la technicité des des outils
utilisés on a voilà tout ce qui est
agriculteur de précisions c'est assez
large donc on est sûr sûr beaucoup
d'action en faveur des agriculteurs mais
toujours sur de l'aide à
l'investissement vous avez parlé du
programme leader qu'est ce qu'ils
signifient c'est quoi l'objectif
ce sont des
comment vous résumer ça jeu
on a deux territoires sur les
départements
porté par
à chaque fois par des associations qui
monte des projets et qui répondent à des
certain nombre d'actions en fait les
porteurs de projets doivent répondre à
un certain nombre de critères c'est
assez compliqué la mise en oeuvre du de
la chose l'articulation je crois qu'on
va recommencer du départ l'articulation
c'est donc
fonds européens qui bascule à la région
qui les dispatche sur les programmes
leader et donc deux territoires
éligibles avec des projets territoriaux
tournée vers l'agriculture
voilà et ça permet d'accompagner un
certain nombre de projets
alors souvent ça peut être sûr de la
transformation des projets liés à des
qui utiliseraient des de la farine
locale ou des
des produits locaux toujours en lien
avec l'agriculture et l'alimentation
parmi les projets soutenus vous avez
celui de son chant grâce à la
méthanisation des agriculteurs peuvent
produire aussi de l'énergie c'est là
aussi à la culture se réinvente aussi et
avec ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
un peu ce procédé ouais bien sûr le
méthaniseur de son chant ce sont six
exploitants six exploitations qui se
sont réunis pour créer un méthaniseur
alors le méthaniseur on enferme des
déchets organiques qui enfermé avec
l'action des bactéries produisent des
gaz c'est un peu ce qui se passe dans
l'estomac de la mâche il me semble sauf
que là ça se passe dans une dans une
machine donc son chant ça va produire du
gaz du méthane qui sera réinjectée dans
le réseau et
ça produit également les méthaniseurs ce
qu'on appelle le digestat donc ses sens
et le jus qui est le résidu de la
méthanisation et qui peut ensuite être
répandu dans les champs parce que c'est
un fertilisant et
c'est une dangereuse c'est une énergie
renouvelable qui part après alors à son
chant ça va alimenter la piscine de
rambouillet l'hôpital et quelques et des
logements
c'est renouvelable
ça permet d'utiliser des déchets
organiques qui serait broyer si
probablement s'il passait pas dans le
méthaniseur et c'est dans une logique de
circuits courts total c'est à dire qu on
injecte on a les produits on sent le
biogaz ce qui va alimenter
du chauffage ou l'électricité localement
et on récupère les digestats qu on
réimplante dans les champs dont les
produits vont venir alimenter le
méthaniseur donc c'est vraiment vraiment
du circuit court et
un complément de revenu pour les pour
les agriculteurs par ailleurs ça crée un
emploi
voilà non c'est une belle réalisation et
c'est tellement circuits courts qu'il ya
un autre méthaniseur avec lequel on
travaille qui est l'unité de
méthanisation trion à carrières sous
poissy je sais pas si si vous le
connaissez la c1 c'est une petite unité
de méthanisation qui récupère les
biodéchets de nos collèges donc c'est
pas un projet qu'on a financé en
revanche on travaille avec eux sur tout
ce qui est bio déchets des collèges et
alors là il rien jacques de gaz dans le
réseau ils peuvent ils ont prévu
d'installer une station
pour recharger des véhicules électriques
qui sont les véhicules qui iront
chercher les biodéchets ou qui iront
redéposer le digestat chez des
exploitants locaux donc là on est encore
plus dans une logique de circuits courts
c'est à dire que tout soutien ensemble
c'est ce sont vraiment des bons outils
pour nos territoires je pense on a parlé
d'énergie renouvelable et concernant les
éoliennes on sait que c'est un débat qui
revient dans la présidentielle les
yvelines sont plutôt en retrait face à
ces projets la cour d'appel
administrative de versailles a mis un
terme à priori définitif au projet de
quatre éoliennes sur un plateau agricole
dans la commune de prunay pas de
stratégie de développement de l'éolien
dans les yvelines donc non pas pour
l'instant ça pose d'autres questions les
éoliennes on s'est intéressé à la
méthanisation
oui sur la méthanisation en plus d'être
un formidable outil pour nos
agriculteurs sur les logiques de
circuits courts je pense que ça va
vraiment dans le sens de l'histoire
c'est la réflexion que je me fais à
chaque fois que j'en vois un nom les
éoliennes non
on n'est pas
on n'est pas positionné dessus alors
nous on n'a pas la compétence énergie
dans le département les méthaniseurs on
est sur nos politiques des deux
agriculteurs jetant un fonds est aussi
dédié en cas de problème climatique est
ce que c'est déjà arrivé que vous
fassiez recours à ce fonds oui alors
la première fois que c'est arrivé on a
aidé nos agriculteurs dans l'urgence
parce qu'il y avait eu un problème alors
je crois que c'était des inondations la
première et on s'est dit bon il faut
pérenniser le système pour être plus
réactifs et donc il est mobilisé il a
été mobilisé pour des épisodes de grêle
qui avaient impacté les arboriculteurs
quand il ya des épisodes de sécheresse
voilà il dépend du nombre d'agriculteurs
du c'est quelque chose qu'on mobilise
régulièrement et probablement de plus en
plus parce que chaque année il ya des
épisodes un peu alors qu'ils touchent
pas toujours toutes les cultures qui
sont pas toujours très médiatisé mais
ouais on est plus en plus confronté un
des épisodes un peu catastrophique pour
pour certains pans de notre agriculture
alors tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de
fournir les collèges en produits locaux
la commune des loges en josas lance la
création d'une ferme biologique qui à
terme fournira les écoles environnantes
et ça aussi le circuit le circuit court
c'est une tendance qui va se développer
dans les années à venir oui oui oui bien
sûr elles avaient les loges en josas en
plus c'est un projet qui a été
accompagné par les politiques
départementales
oui à la fois c'est ça a du sens c'est à
dire que l'écologie c'est aussi
préserver l'environnement s'est fait
attention au bilan carbone quand on est
vraiment sur ces logiques de circuits
courts le bilan carbone il est
extrêmement réduit on est sur une
saisonnalité des produits voilà manger
de la tomate bio en hiver quand elle est
produite à l'étranger dans des serres ou
sanaa où même pas dans des serres mais à
l'étranger ça n'a pas de sens terre
qu'elle est bio mais qu'elle a voyagé
donc le le coût pour l'environnement est
important même si elle est estampillée
bio donc le circuit coin la saisonnalité
ça évite ce genre de d'incohérences je
pense donc pour les collèges vous
comment ça se passe vous dites à la
société de gestion des restaurants de se
fournir directement auprès des produits
locaux ou c'est vous qui faites le lien
entre les deux alors on a créé une
société d'économie mixte c'est à dire
que c'est pas une vraie délégation de
service public parce que cette société
le département siège au sein de son
conseil d'administration ce qui nous
permet
d'avoir un
oeil sur les orientations qui sont
prises qui de toute façon avaient été
fixées par le cahier des charges initial
qui fonctionnait comme un
un marché public une procédure de mise
en concurrence
on avait des objectifs
qui étaient fixés par ce cahier des
charges et maintenant on vérifie qu'ils
sont bien mis en oeuvre c'est pas nous
qui allons
les mettre en place et le prestataire
qui qui voient ça directement avec les
producteurs
l'idée c'est à la fois d'avoir des
produits dans les assiettes de nos
collégiens d'avoir une juste
rémunération de nos producteurs et
pourquoi pas à terme
et même à terme de prévoir à des de
permettre à des agriculteurs de
diversifier en faisant du maraîchage
pour ça il faut qu'ils puissent porter
des investissements assez lourd qui vont
avec il faut qu'ils soient d'accord qui
porte ses investissements et pour porter
des investissements il faut qu'ils aient
la garantie
laurent dutoit leur marché intérieur qui
est un marché derrière avec des prix
garantis c'est ça qui est encore
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre
j'espère que des textes comme la loi et
galim où nous aideront à y parvenir
voilà parce que c'est pas juste entre le
département et les producteurs ou entre
notre opérateur et les producteurs pour
finir il ya aussi les amap les
associations pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne les ivy n'en compte
pas moins de 65 que pensez vous de ces
associations c'est dans la même voie la
même idée oui c'est 1 1 c'est un
débauché encore différent pour
pour nos exploitants surtout en
maraîchage qui répond à une demande
de nos habitants on a la chance dans le
département des yvelines et plus
généralement en ile-de-france dans un
bassin de consommateurs
très important est d'avoir les débouchés
donc ça fait partie de ces logiques de
circuits courts je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de projets et de la place pour
beaucoup de projets tout aussi différent
qu'ils soient les uns des autres merci
beaucoup je suis un prix pauline vinocur
lefebvre d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes la vice
présidente du conseil départemental des
yvelines et nous on se retrouve bientôt
pour un nouveau numéro de l'hebdo
politique très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique